esta es la primera vez que se hace el
esfuerzo global de la juventud con más
de 40 mil firmas que se han obtenido a
través de todos los países del mundo
meramente consultando a
ministerios a organizaciones a
universidades y generalmente un llamado
a los jóvenes para que se unan en esta
declaratoria histórica
las demandas primero que nada a los
gobiernos y a los políticos que tienen
es que planean postularse les exigimos
que se tomen esto con seriedad tienen
que involucrar a los científicos y la
perspectiva del panel intergubernamental
primero antes de diseñar las políticas y
después tienen que asegurarse de que
sean efectivas e inclusivas y también se
les va a ser responsables a largo plazo
de las decisiones que hayan tomado
entonces moviéndonos con el aspecto de
inclusividad tengo que celebrar que esta
es una de las cosas que más
representación latinoamericana ha tenido
y eso verdaderamente es algo de lo que
como mexicano estoy muy orgulloso así
que
mientras estos son grandísimas noticias
todavía no se encuentran estas personas
en las mesas de decisiones en donde
primero tienen que ser consultados ellos
dado que son las zonas más vulnerables
los que primero sufren el impacto del
cambio climático ya los que último se
les pregunta de normal esto incluye a
grupos indígenas personas de color
de las personas con discapacidad
etcétera etcétera y pues moviéndome para
no quitar más tiempo hacia mi campo de
expertise que sería en ciudad de
ciudades sostenibles e involucra
tanto las acciones financieras que se
deben de tomar para la economía circular
el transporte y la movilidad sostenible
dentro de todas las ciudades la
infraestructura energética que debe ser
modernizada sobre todo de dónde
provienen estas energías y qué se hace
con los desechos que generan